every class in destiny is made up of two
subclasses each with its own unique
special abilities skill modifiers and
stylistic nuances however because you
can't unlock your Guardians second
subclass until level 15 we're breaking
down the pros and cons of each one ahead
of time so you can make an informed
decision because nobody wants to four
hours into a character only to discover
that at half sucks first up is the void
Walker the warlock starting subclass the
void Walker is the darker edgier
subclass of the two focusing primarily
on dealing damage draining the very life
from foes and putting them in a deeply
uncomfortable position much like the way
back seat in my Volvo the void Walker
super ability is the Nova bomb a massive
projectile that deals devastating damage
in a large area of effect this secret
weapon is clutch in pvp and PVE
situations alike and it only grows more
powerful over time as later skill
unlocks place a damaging vortex at the
site of impact and split the Nova into
multiple smaller bombs not only is this
super ability super powerful but it's
also super satisfying to use dumping an
energy ball on your enemies and watching
them dissolve into the ether is the
Destiny equivalent of peeling that
plastic screen off a new monitor the
starting grenade of the void Walker is
much like a weaker version of the Nova
bomb as it creates a damaging vortex
much in the same way these two abilities
add an element of crowd control to the
Warlock that strengthens the classes
secondary role as a support class the
void Walker's other grenades are a
scatter bomb which I found greatly
underpowered in the axiom bolt which
seems to be some sort of Sith Lord Chain
Lightning ability that I have yet to
unlock the death-dealing doesn't end
here however as the void Walker's energy
drain ability is equally useful for
putting down intergalactic scoundrels
this skill allows your melee to suck the
life from your foes recharging your
grenades at their expense the surge
ability modifier further empowers your
melee strikes by granting temporarily
increased weapon and movement speed
after each successful use additional
upgrades caused the ability to recharge
your Nova bomb and steal health with a
kill shot as well increasing the
survivability and deadliness of the
glass cannon that is the Warlock after
passing level 15
Destiny's og space wizard has the
opportunity to opt into the aptly named
sunsinger class the Sunseeker is not
incredibly different than the stock
warlock at first their stat modifiers
are exactly the same and glide jump
unlocks are nearly
however as you progress deeper into the
skill tree the advantages and
disadvantages become increasingly
apparent most prominent is the
replacement of the nova bomb at the
radiant skill at first many of you may
feel the same pang of disappointment
that I did whereas my giant spirit bomb
you might ask well fear not because
radiance does indeed have a purpose
beyond the human glow stick angle
activating this skill causes the
warlocks other abilities to regenerate
at a ridiculous rate allowing you to
spam out a handful of grenades and a
couple fiery punches in short order
before you run out of juice considering
the Sun sickness grenades among which
are a fire Spectre look-alike of the
vortex and a halo esque sticky grenade
this is a fairly decent replacement for
the Nova bomb it's worth noting the gift
of the Sun also grants an extra grenade
for each recharge enabling you to make
it literally rain maids when combined
with your super further unlocks enable
radiance to reduce allies cooldowns
reducing coming damage and self revive
from the grave giving the sun singer a
distinctly support and survival oriented
tinge much like a priest or a paladin of
the MMO ilk the melee ability for the
sunsinger is called scorch and it is
very satisfying this fits squarely into
a few fire based abilities that ignite
enemies for more damage after the
initial hit deeper into the skill tree
scorch also triggers a flame shield upon
a successful kill significantly reducing
damage for a short time which could make
all the difference during a hairy fire
fight overall the sunsinger seems to be
best suited for individuals who prefer
to play with groups or support others
rather than dish out pure unadulterated
damage honestly though in my time with
destiny I felt a definite preference for
the void Walker subclass it's not that
the sunsinger is a bad choice it's just
that I felt the radiance ability defuse
the damage I was capable of dishing out
into many small bursts via grenades and
melee strikes as opposed to the Nova
bomb which funnels all that damage into
one controlled burst
further the capability to leech help
from gran amis with melee is possibly
the most useful skill on the warlock
pack considering the fragility of the
space mage well you can always switch
back and forth between the two classes
you'll only accrue skills for the class
that's currently active so be mindful of
what you've got equipped if you're
reaching for that next ability unlock
don't be timid though give both the shot
for yourself before you decide which
one's for you you're a space wizard
goddammit and nobody tells the space
wizard what to do
you